au bord de la mer d'azov des ukrainiens
dans la crainte d'une attaque russe un
scénario qui l'ont déjà vécu
cette femme se souvient très bien des
roquettes lancées par les séparatistes
pro-russes
c'était en 2015 et si l'histoire se
répétait
mes papiers sont prêts pour le cas où il
faudrait partir vif ou le reste tout ce
qui est matériel ce n'est pas bien grave
marioupol est le poumon économique du
sud de l'ukraine mais ce port ses usines
ses trains de marchandises fonctionne au
ralenti
parce que la région est littéralement
cerner voir asphyxié par moscou au nord
de marioupol la zone séparatiste pro
russe à l'est la russie au sud la crim
est annexée par vladimir poutine
le responsable du port dénonce ce qu'il
appelle le harcèlement de moscou
dans la mer d'azov des gardes côtes
russes se comportent comme s'ils étaient
chez eux il arrête le bateau sous
n'importe quel prétexte fumi les stop
pendant des jours pour des enquêtes le
seul but est d'empêcher nos bateaux
d'entrer et de sortir
une mère que vladimir poutine a en
quelque sorte fermé avec ce pont un
ouvrage de 19 km qui relie la russie à
la crimée mario paul dépend donc
désormais du bon vouloir des russes pour
sortir vers la mer d'azov est exporté
vers le monde entier
à la sortie des entreprises les ouvriers
se lamente eux aussi car cet enclavement
perturbe beaucoup
l'approvisionnement en matières
premières
les russes pas tarder les bateaux qui
arrivent nous empêche de travailler
correctement cela des conséquences
énormes sur les grosses usines de la
région
sur ce port 15 millions de tonnes de
marchandises étaient embarqués chaque
année c'est désormais moitié moins ce
port et cette mer d'azov sont d'une
importance cruciale pour l'économie
ukrainienne
les russes vont ils tenter de s'emparer
de cette zone c'est en tout cas l'un des
multiples scénarios d'invasion